in this morning's ion money today is the
first day you can apply for college
financial aid for the next school year
the Free Application for Federal Student
Aid or FAFSA determines grants loans and
work-study money for more than 12
million students each year the program
gives more than one hundred and twenty
two billion dollars away in some form
CBS News business analyst Jill
Schlesinger is here with what families
need to know billions of dollars they
can start going for it today yeah FAFSA
fafsa.gov hard to say and this is so
important because as you said we're
talking about so much money but the
process can be daunting
just remember this this is where you get
scholarships and grants and loans and
work-study so this is your gateway into
the system now I know a lot of people
they say oh I don't want to do it I'm
not going to qualify you know there are
estimates that more than two million
students could have gotten money free
money in some cases but they didn't go
through the process so you're
encouraging people qualify even if you
don't think you even if you don't think
rolla trouble yes because every
circumstance is different you might say
I make a lot of money but you might make
a lot of money and have three kids in
school at the same time or maybe one of
you has lost an income or reduced hours
keep trying this is the only way to get
it is it first-come first-served Jill
some of the money is first-come
first-serve and I should mention there
is a nother form because one form is not
enough this is what we're talking about
you know billions of dollars through
FAFSA there's another form through the
College Board the CSS profile which
releases nine billion dollars a year not
as much but that's for non-federal aid
these two programs in concert will get
most of the people money they need 55%
of students pay for school with some
form of grant scholarship or work stuff
roughly how much time should people set
aside to do this today the Department of
Education it's 30 minutes I mean I
really don't think it's 30 minutes but
what you should do is you want to
prepare for it so you have Social
Security numbers now by the way this is
one of those hurdles because you didn't
need your social security number but
let's say you're a single parent you
that have to go to your ex and say
give me your social we're applying for
financial aid you need your financial
documents it can be a drag and I get
that but you get all of your ducks in a
row a couple of hours I think if we said
to people we'll give you $1,000 to take
a couple of hours to take Instagram
photos of your pets they would do it
yeah we are talking about tens of
thousands of dollars so it's worth it's
gonna take a little longer than 30
minutes but you know college costs keep
going up and up it's scary to think how
much it's gonna cost for kids born today
what what conversation should parents
and kids have well while you're deciding
college or not I think that as early as
freshman you're in high school you can
start having conversations that say this
hey we are a family we know a college
degree is worth it because you'll have
lifetime earnings that are higher but we
can only afford so much as a family make
it a family conversation all right Jill
Schlesinger thanks